justice is blind oh there you are
Netflix just dropped their trailer to
the upcoming daredevil series and
honestly it looks awesome
sorry their table I mean it also sounds
awesome too right
I'm Jamie potato and today we're going
to go through the daredevil trailer and
make some predictions of what might
happen this is hashtag news
there's a lot that goes down in this
gritty reboot so let's get into it
when I was a kid I used to dream what it
would be like to live somewhere far away
from Hell's Kitchen the show is still
set in Hell's Kitchen but if it's
anything like the Hell's Kitchen of
modern New York it's gonna be mostly
expensive coffee shops and nightclubs is
that a crime down there but I realized
the city was a part of me it was in my
blood this big scary bald guy is kingpin
the archenemy of daredevil why he's
staring at a blank canvas is beyond me
I just spent Modern Art's I don't and I
would do anything to make it a better
place
a lot of kingpin so far we're thirty
seconds in and we haven't even seen or
heard from daredevil aka Matt Murdock I
thinking this show will be just as much
about the rise of kingpin as it is about
daredevil this is why everyone is so
excited about this version versus the
old version Marvel is on a roll with its
latest reboot and we can only hope that
this is no exception
good and evil sometimes the difference
between the two is a sharp line and here
is Ben Urich investigative reporter in
the comics this is the guy who
ultimately reveals daredevil secret
identity but works with him to take down
kingpin it's gonna be interesting to see
if this series follows that story
looking at these cards he's trying to
track down kingpin who is responsible
for a recent heroin epidemic
take a look sometimes it's a blur
sometimes oh the humble beginnings of
Matt Murdock and his best lawyer friend
foggy Nelson this cardboard sign shows
they're just starting their law firm so
we'll be seeing the earliest years of
daredevil we have to do
we're gonna make a difference and just
like that they have a plaque which means
that they're in the big leagues now
or that plaques are super cheap to come
back I know it doesn't feel like it
sometimes but we are you're applying it
whoa Thank You Claire temple for
clearing that up
rosario Dawson will be playing a
combination of night nurse and Claire
temple who will probably be a caretaker
of daredevil but you see so much I hear
things so we're going to see young Matt
Murdoch and his Obi Wan type mentor
stick what they call stuff like that
beautiful stick trains Murdock she uses
hypersensitive hearing to basically see
and beat the crap out of bad guys there
are other ways to see here we go
there's shady looking Karen Paige
looking like she's up to no good I hope
she doesn't stick too closely to the
comics and get addicted to heroin and
cause personal turmoil for daredevil
throughout the entire season women am i
right I don't see the city anymore
there's only dark corners whoo hopefully
the show is dark is the lighting Karen
Karen page is the love interest of both
Matt Murdock and foggy Nelson I have to
be the man this city needs what are you
gonna do whatever it takes
oh here he's wearing his rented
daredevil costume from the trial of the
Incredible Hulk does that mean we might
see some Hulk action I'm sure he'll get
his classic red costume soon enough Oh
red ninja alerts the guy that kicks him
in the face is wearing a red robe which
must mean that he's part of the band
and here is a young Matt Murdock right
after the accident that left him blind
so with all of the flashbacks that looks
like his origin story will be a regular
part of this series and there goes his
dad into the fight that he refuses to
throw don't do it jack boiler another
man's evil does not make you good I
respected conviction the lone man thinks
he can make a difference just trying to
make my city a better place
the city was a part of me it was my
blood and I would do anything to make it
a better place
so both Daredevil and kingpin wants to
make the city a better place but who's
right and who's wrong I'm looking
forward to a lot of moral ambiguity
maybe she had an iron suit or magic
hammer probably I would explain why you
keep getting your asses attitude okay
does it wisely think Iron Man and Thor
are cooler than daredevil cuz that
they're not I'm excited this looks like
a return of the gritty 80s style comics
that we know and love the ones that
Frank Miller and John Romita I can't
wait now that lips continues to dominate
original programming but seriously
hoping for a crossover thank you guys so
much for watching and if you liked this
breakdown go subscribe for more
comic-book coverage like this video if
you love daredevil just like we do and
comment below if there's other trailers
that you want to see us break down for
you in the meantime just stay tuned for
brand new videos from new media
rockstars I'm Jaime apetito and I'm
gonna solve some crimes coming for you
in